who do you think
is the strongest character in the game
and who do you think the strongest
character is in the movie
i think jax is the strongest i think
i think skill wise is kung lao yeah
that's uh that's a good one
i think when i was playing the video
game oh my god
fans are going to try to fans are going
to come at me for this but i can't
remember the freaking character's name
he was a horse i think his name is
montaro or
montaro or something like that he's half
horse half human
and he just did this horse kick you all
the time and it was so hard to beat that
dude
montaro i think i took a shot at it i
probably did it but anyway
um and then on set um well
it's got to be sub-zero he's he's
menacing and um
mataro yeah i was right so um yeah
sub-zero he
he's menacing and um joe taslim who
plays him did such a fantastic job in
performance so yeah that was it um
he's definitely the scariest dude uh i
know it's not in the movie
uh but did you guys ever joke around and
discuss uh what your friendship would be
yeah that's a good one i like that one
what would your friendship be bro
well jax has a friendship right he's got
he's got the saxophone i
i think i would take the saxophone and i
would beat the [ __ ] out of lewistown
no it's a friendship not a fatality
that's how i treat my friends bro i'll
tell you what it is because this
actually happened in real life
mccod's friendship would be he would
invite you over to his house and there'd
be all these cameras lit
and he would sit you down on a yoga mat
and he would do a sound healing
that's true
yeah that's true that's that was my that
was my birthday
so that so the whole cast came over and
we did a sound healing so that
that would be that would be my
friendship move i went to a different i
went to a different realm i went to
outworld
i left my body i would i would uh i
would invite you over for it for a more
sound healing that's right
one of the things about the game i think
that we can all agree are some of the
fatalities are
brutal um who do you think has the most
brutal fatality in the video game
i don't want to give the spoilers away
from the movie so i'd say in the game
elena's got one where she goes she puts
her hand through somebody's torso
and then rips their face out from the
inside out
which is just disrespectful and i love
it
yeah i like the one when scorpion uh
hits the head
and shoots his spear through the head um
smoking's got some
some some pretty crazy ones uh yeah but
i think you might be right molina might
be the most vicious
of all of them i'm just gonna say thank
you guys i hope it's a huge hit and you
guys get to make more
thank you